North and South, your combat prowess and brilliant strategy could rewrite history.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
And I'm Sean.
You could rewrite history.
Uh huh. Yeah.
Is that really like, is that the selling point of the game?
Did you have the chance to right some wrongs?
No. I don't, I think it's just for people that are very interested in that time period, Mike.
Agreed, agreed.
North and South is a mashup of a turn-based strategy game and real-time action.
What I'll be calling party games.
Uh, because I want to make this sound like Mario Party as much as possible throughout the episode.
But it's all wrapped under a civil war campaign.
That's right. The North and South that are in the title of the game are referring to the North and the South, uh, fighting in the Civil War between the years.
The American Civil War.
Right. The American Civil War, 1861 to 1864.
Uh, you know, it, it basically approached, the game is approached from a risk light, which is funny because we were talking about risk last week for no good reason.
But you have this map where, uh, you know, each state is a, uh, is a territory up for grabs by both the North and the South.
And, uh, you want to, just like in risk, you want to conquer all the territories.
You want to do that here.
But in order to do so, it isn't just, uh, my number's bigger than your number, roll some dice thing.
It's actually, uh, each, each time you try to take something over, turns into a little party game where the armies collide.
Or you try to, uh, steal the railroad.
Or you try to infiltrate a, uh, uh, uh, what, what is that?
Is that just like a town?
Is that a, is that?
It's a fort. Okay.
Yeah. Try to infiltrate the fort.
Uh, all these little things to just spice up the gameplay a little bit.
So it isn't just risk or it isn't just strategy.
They're adding, they're adding some video game components to this.
Otherwise, what would be if we're looking at some of our grander strategy games that we've played by Koei.
This isn't that.
So first question is the main appeal, the strategy layer, or is it really the fact that the strategy is just a way to trigger these mini games?
Um, that's a good question.
Um, I, I would say that, yes, I think my, I think the main appeal is the strategy because I don't think that there's any real depth in the mini games.
Um, and if I can, if I may, I think that this is finally the kind of strategy game that I was looking for on the system.
Um, I think I got a little bit ahead of myself when I said at one point that I was looking forward to something such as, um, uh, Nobunaga's ambition or romance, the three kingdoms or Genghis Khan or whatever the hell else we played recently.
Um, this is what, this is more what I'm looking for.
Uh, something that has strategy, um, but isn't just a giant spreadsheet.
Yes.
Agreed. Uh, the one we played most recently was Bandit Kings of Ancient China.
I remind you, sounds like a, uh, a song wings would have wrote, uh, in the late seventies.
Uh, yes, I agree with you.
I think that, uh, especially on an eight bit system, this makes more sense, but I don't want you to forget.
And I'm pretty sure back then you were, you were playing all the games too.
So I think you were on the episode defender of the crown.
That was kind of a game like this.
That was like strategy adjacent.
There weren't like the party.
Uh, I I'm sorry.
I'm not, I can't call them party games any longer.
I really wanted to force it, but they're really just like light mini games.
Um, that do have, that do have fail states.
Like you, it's not just like there.
And there is depth to the one-on-one combat.
Not so much the raid the train, but yeah, there's depth there.
But it's all everything.
Both the, the fact that there is a civil war, the fact that, um, you conquer these states,
the fact that you fight off in a war, it's all kind of done under this, uh, cartoonish,
uh, like comic vibe with both the art style and just like the overall behavior of, uh, like
the animation in general.
And that's because the game is an adaptation of, uh, like a French comic about the American
civil war, uh, Les Tuniques Bleu, uh, which is the blue coats.
And, um, I, I guess like, is that necessary?
Like I did not look into this comic at all because I didn't feel like, I don't feel like
a, it doesn't feel like a licensed thing.
Like, yeah, I could be inspired by that, but is it really like enough of a thing?
Like it just, this kind of feels like a standalone game.
You don't need to know any other material other than the fact that the civil war happened.
Well, I think that's why, unlike a lot of situations where, you know, a game would be based on a property
that we just don't have in the States, they didn't find any reason to change anything because
maybe it, maybe it's beloved in Belgium or wherever the fuck it's from, but.
Oh, you're right. No, it is Belgium.
Yeah. But it, to us, it just looks like a cartoonish version of the civil war, which is a choice in
the States, but, um, I think it still works.
If you're going to make a civil war game, then why not just use what's already been made?
It's a, it treats a serious subject with cartoon visuals.
And so I ask you, does the light tone of it all make it easier to approach playing this
game as the South or does it flatten the whole thing?
And just, you know, it's like window dressing for kind of a, an outcome that's just not comfortable
for a North American landscape.
I can totally understand why, like, you know, similar to, you know, playing as the, uh, the
Japanese in, in some of the world war two shmups, why it's like, it's okay.
But like, it, you know, the civil war game happening and being released in America.
Yeah. Do you know, there's, there's some conflict there.
Um, I mean, this isn't the only, Oh no.
Yeah. We'll get into it.
This isn't the only civil war, uh, like strategy game.
I, I don't think there's any, but yeah, your point it being kind of this light, I don't
have a problem with it.
I think there's also like much weirder things going on in this game than just the fact that
it is a civil war, uh, cartoony game.
Um, I, I think I like the first moment that I like thought, Oh, this is going to be weird
is when in the opening sort of summary, uh, when you start a game in 19 and sorry, in 19,
in 1861, uh, it says that the Confederates stormed, uh, Fort Sumner, which is not a thing
or a real place.
Um, but it was, it was just, I was just sort of like stealing myself for like, this is going
to be weird and it ended up being weird, but we'll, we'll get there.
We'll get there. Yeah.
So you, you pick a side, the union or the Confederacy, and, um, then you can start the campaign
in, in all different years between 1861 to 1864.
And that does change the, the opening.
So it's kind of like a, a chess thing where the opening board, it can be a little different
dependent on skill level and everything and how you want to go about that.
But the practical objective is to take territories, build up your army through the income gained,
uh, mostly through the railroad where the railroad is key in this game and then grind the opponent
down until they cannot hold any more of their states.
When you win in this game or even just make progress, do you feel like it is because of
a combination of smart positioning and being good at the mini games?
Or is it, is it like predominantly like just a numbers game or just a, I'm really good with
a controller? I think it's, I'm really good with a controller, at least when it comes to like the one-on-one
battles. Um, I think it's important to wait, that we actually kind of give a little bit of an overview
of how these work. Um, yeah.
You have, uh, infantry, cavalry, and artillery.
Now, if this were any other strategy game that we've ever played, there would be like
a turn-based, like select what they do.
And then you would watch that occur maybe.
Um, or it would just be a literal number cruncher calculator, which would say like, oh, civilization
style, like, uh, which, which of these wins.
Um, but no, you go with however, whatever the number of infantry, whatever the number
of cavalry and however many, uh, uh, giant cannons you have.
And you have.
The cannons are, the cannons are the brute force.
Yeah. That is, yeah.
You live and die by your cannon.
So, you have to concurrently control all three of these things.
Now, they make it simple enough to switch between control of sending your cavalry forward, manually
controlling the formation, and, uh, like, fine-tuning where your infantry goes.
And then you have a more, like, you have like a, it's a longer shot selection for the artillery.
But you have to do everything at once.
And you kind of just have to be really good at multitasking.
Um, so there is a big skill.
I don't know about a big skill ceiling, but skill at this part of the game can determine
whether you win the strategy portion, whether or not you're any good at strategy, I think.
Yeah, it's a great point because there, there's, there, the way that they position you, too,
it is just, like, one side's on the left, one side's on the right, and then depending
on where you are, there's, like, a river or a canyon, and then there's some bridges that
you have to cross over, and...
Sometimes. There's also just big open fields where there's just, like, trees to go around.
That's true. I guess what, my, my point being is that, like, you would think whoever has more troops
is going to win, but Deshaun's point about multitasking, I did play this game with Joe
who couldn't be here.
Um, but when we versed each other, there were times for both of us where it was just, like,
you know, a misplay on the controller could completely screw up, like, you, you could get
your cavalry over to the cannons and get the job done.
And it didn't always guarantee, like, the numbers game, and so could, the tide could
change very fast, um, in something that should have been a sure thing now becomes, like, a,
um, you know, a risky decision of, like, well, my opponent might be better at me than this,
so I don't know if I want to go win there while they have equal amount of troops.
Yeah, and then there's the fact that you, however many troops are left, if, like, if you did win,
but it was, like, you only just barely won, or if you somehow, uh, retreated, like, that
unit now only has as many, like, they might only have, like, two infantry left, or they'll
just have the cannon.
So, you then have to sort of sacrifice a pawn on the board to reinforce, um, and, uh, and
wait for the train to come around to actually pay you enough taxes to get another unit.
Um, so, it can be, once you lose a battle, it can be kind of like a death spiral.
As far as, like, for the strategy layer, uh, it's turn-based movement.
On your turn, you move armies from state to adjacent state, um, and you can move all your
units, too, so there is a lot of, uh, movement going on, and everybody can see this, too.
It's not like you can hide what you're doing from, uh, your opposition.
The, the part of me that, like, maybe it's too simple, is, like, I do kind of wish, I'm
not trying to ask for it to be, like, a whole nother game, but that there was some kind of,
like, Oregon Trail component of, like, moving an army across different state geographies.
Like, if you're crossing a river or something, that there could be some potential, like,
dysentery or casualties along the way of, like, just, you know, things that just go wrong when
you're trying to, you know, command an army.
In the grand step strategy space, we call that attrition.
Okay, sure, you know, like, just, just little things that could potentially happen.
It doesn't have to be, again, a whole thing that, like, the player has to control, but just,
to, to spice up, uh, and make, like, you know, oh, crossing a river versus, like, well, this is just,
you know, crossing, you know, uh, land to land as opposed to, like, over a mountain or something.
Like, just maybe a little more strategy there is a little too simple, but once you get over that,
uh, you, there are multiple ways to capture states, and, and it's not, it doesn't always
involve conflict.
They're, first off, depending on what year you pick, there might be empty states,
so there, you might immediately rush to those states because once you land on an empty state,
you acquire it.
It's like monopoly rules, but you don't even have to pay anything.
Then, if there are enemy-controlled states with their flag but no defending army, you capture those.
Then if, uh, but you do have to, um, you do have to infiltrate their fort.
Uh, then there, uh, states that are occupied by, yeah, if it has a fort.
Then there are states occupied by the enemy army where you have to do the battle that we were talking about with the three
different units. And last but not least, there are the rail towns.
Um, those are the ones that force
the fort minigame.
Um, and, and you have to, uh, take down, you have to basically get, it's a race
against the clock to get to the flag at the end.
It's kind of weird. It's like Super Mario Brothers.
You're, you're in like a side-scrolling stage where you have to try to get to the flag within the time
limit. But the other player, whether it's a human or the computer, kind of just randomly spawns into
the screen every now and again and, and gets in your way.
They have a certain amount of lives.
You have infinite lives.
You just have to, uh, you know, like they're just basically blocking you
off to not be completed in time.
Yes, exactly.
But I don't want to, I want to focus on the
strategy layer before we get too into the games because I feel like it's best to break these
things up. There, there are other things you can do.
You can join forces, you can merge your armies.
So if you have, uh, like one cannon and two cavalry, and then you have three cannons and eight infantry,
you can merge those together by moving one into the other, but you can never undo a merge.
Yeah. So it is, it's very permanent.
It's very purposeful.
It, it doesn't feel like a bug to me.
It feels, uh, like something that they put in design.
So this way you couldn't just
do this without any kind of repercussions.
And then you can also, um, you can do surround captures,
which is something that didn't come up in, in my experiences, but you can theoretically own
all of the states of occupying an adjacent state.
And then just like you surround that state and,
and acquire it. That is pretty cool too.
Making giant like perimeter breaches.
It is cool.
Um, but now that we're talking about this layer, um, especially, and I guess only if you're playing
against the computer, it's very, it's very easy, um, to just not see any of this.
Because you've just rushed the two enemies that are on the board in an 1861 start,
and you may have won those battles and the game is over six months into what the war would have been.
Um, right. So I think this is definitely like stuff you might see in a multiplayer game,
which I think is the correct way to play this game.
Um, it's just that there, and I, again,
I only played, uh, on level one of the, like playing as the North against a level one confederacy,
uh, in 1861, where there's only a couple of units on the board.
So I felt like I was missing a lot.
Like this just, it's got all of the bones of a, like a simple strategy game, but one that seems pretty fun.
Uh, it just felt like there wasn't enough time for me to see everything.
Uh, so I guess I could have played it on harder difficulty to get to that point and actually explore
those, uh, strategy layers, but I ended up not doing that.
Yeah. I mean, I also think it just comes down to the kind of, uh, whether it's a computer opponent
or a human opponent, it just comes down to the situation.
Cause I think a lot of those things
that I described, you, you might, if it's a human opponent, you might face someone who also plays
similar to you, right?
Very like, okay, you're going here, I'm going there.
And then there are other ones who are like, well, I want to capture those rail towns.
You can take every other state.
I don't give a shit.
You know, it's like, there are, there are different outcomes to the game
where it's not just so simple of like, uh, I just have to eliminate every, um, uh, every opponent
because there's a whole, like after everybody's gone, there's a replenishing stage of the, you
know, the, the States that you, uh, that you own and especially the ones that are connected
to the railroad, those help generate new soldiers, which are very important, um, to the game
because they, again, soldiers aren't even just an individual soldier on that battlefield.
They count as a whole like division, right?
A whole division that can continue to conquer, uh, states
that aren't occupied.
So, you know, you might have an incredible army by merging everybody together,
but you're just one unit on the screen moving around, whereas somebody else could have five
smaller units occupying five different turns that they can make.
So there is still some like
there's not a ton of depth, like not enough that I feel like a 10 year old couldn't at least attempt
this game. Like Nobunaga, I feel like is out of a 10 year old's reach, but there is still some good
decision making here to be had.
Uh, especially when you introduce the optional stuff, you know,
there's the ability to introduce, uh, storms and, uh, Europe and, uh, native Americans and Mexicans
into the game.
Yeah. And, and all those things are like, you know, optional additional ways to,
so the native Americans and the Mexicans are, uh, they can periodically attack.
Uh, I think the Mexicans, uh, what is it?
Do they attack whoever owns Texas?
They're very much, they're always on a
siesta until they decide to trigger and they will, I think they'll attack a unit that's in one of the
southern spaces, but right.
Okay. Uh, and then the native Americans are kind of like that only they're
always on the lookout.
Um, and we'll attack you if you're in more of the Midwest spaces.
So, uh, very
French wave, uh, maybe American, but I think, uh, the French can get off easy on this maybe.
Yeah. Yeah. The, the storm cloud, uh, which I had all these turned on in my game against Joe,
um, the storm cloud makes it so that whatever, wherever the storm is on that state, you can't,
you, the army on that state cannot move.
Uh, you, and so like that happened and that was kind of,
that's kind of, I guess what I was looking for, for movement in general is just more of that kind
of stuff to just not, not even introduce some randomness, but just make it so that it felt more,
like I wasn't just, uh, moving pieces across board spaces, but that it actually felt like a real
environment that, you know, you were trying to conquest.
I did like that.
Um, maybe not so much
the, uh, the context for the other two, but something like weather change, uh, just like giving you some
actual geography or something to actually, uh, uh, differentiate, uh, so that it's not just
a symmetrical game, um, is always good.
Something to throw a wrench into it, uh, makes it feel like a
more engaging strategic situation.
And the last one, the European reinforcements, uh, a boat will, um, come to the United States,
to whoever is occupying North Carolina and, uh, deliver reinforcements.
Uh, and obviously like
the, uh, the French were instrumental in, uh, changing the tide of the civil war.
So I think this is the one that feels kind of weird that it's optional, but instrumental in turning the tide of
the civil war. Weren't they like they supplied the arms that they, that the North desperately needed
and they could have went with the South.
Oh, they were kind of like a, let them fight for a while.
And then they just chose the union.
I thought they were just, I thought it was more like a
revolutionary war thing and not so much a civil war, but I guess, I don't know.
They just keep
coming back. They just can't get their hands off of America.
The French are rose, huh? I know.
Right. And what do we do for them?
We rename our fries.
Uh, yes, no, but it's true.
It's not, it's not as big as the American revolution where obviously like, you know, who knows what the
outcome would have been. It would have just been longer, but, uh, definitely, definitely would
have been longer. But, uh, here I think it's interesting that they make it North Carolina
because making it one state, as opposed to just the coast in general, like kind of supplying the
coast via boat makes it so much more important.
Like it, it, it, it can't be stressed to how valuable
reinforcements are in this game.
And that's why, again, you go after the railroads and you go after
North Carolina, um, because those ones will continuously deliver basically arms for you to not
be brute forced out by your opponent.
Um, in, in the mini game section, you'll still always have a
supply of people.
Speaking of with the railroad and everything, the, after everybody makes the moves,
the train also, um, makes it stops.
And if basically whatever you, whatever railroad towns you own,
you collect a tax on those.
And when you collect five bags of gold, you get a new army unit.
And so you can have multiple, uh, if you own all the rail, you can get enough to have everything.
So me and Joe really fought over those railroad States and didn't really care about what was going on
in Maine or new or New York.
Cause the map is kind of weird.
I guess it's a very strange map.
Uh, but I think it mostly works.
I think that, uh, it's, I guess, um, what am I trying to say here?
I think this would make a really good board game.
I don't really know how you would, I don't know how
you would sort of make the, uh, the, the mini games or like the battles actually engaging and
not just like a dice roll.
Uh, but, uh, you do like duck, duck, goose.
Yeah. But it seems like
they didn't really care so much for, you know, geography or, uh, historic railroad routes.
Um, but that sea really makes it hard to control the whole thing.
So it's at least designed for balance.
So that's pretty cool.
Also, I think we mentioned it, but like, if you are in enemy territory and
happen upon, uh, one of these towns, you can just sort of get some wild west boarding of a,
uh, boarding of a train and he'd kind of do like a variation of the, uh, of the fort mini game.
Um, it's, it's interesting.
Yeah. And I think both of those, we can go a little more in depth on
those now, both whether it's the fort or the train, still the same idea.
You control a single
soldier, uh, in a side scrolling level, just running to the right under a time limit.
Uh, you have, uh, like knives that you can throw, right?
You throw the knives. You are a knife
throwing soldier.
Yeah. No guns, no such thing as guns.
Uh, and then you, once you run out of knives,
you can punch. Um, and, and so in the fort, there's obstacles, like there's dogs, there's
explosives, there's ladders you have to climb because obstacles make it this way.
You can't, you can't, you don't have like a jump button.
Uh, you have, so you have to, if something's in your
way, you have to climb up a building to go around it.
Uh, typical, you know, uh, fort stuff.
And then as long as you, there's like a, there's a, a boot and there's a clock, like, like a typical
clock that you would to stop an alarm clock.
It's like a boot with like a mouth.
Yes. And both those
things are at the bottom of the screen racing against each other, but it's actually the boot
is you and the clock is time.
And so you have to try and this sounds very complicated.
It's actually pretty easy and can be fun.
I think they messed this up though.
And I think I could speak for Joe
here too, because it lost him the game, but I think they messed it up because of how the opponent
spawns into both of these, whether it's the train or the fort, the, the one, the single soldier
running to the right is basically invincible, can only be temporarily knocked out.
And the
opposition can, can control how they spawn in.
Like, I think you hit the button to confirm
that you want to come in, but you do just kind of pop in to the screen.
It's not like you,
you, you just kind of spawn out of thin air and it creates some awkward encounters and it makes
it a little easier for the, uh, the defender.
Yeah. The attacker to, to anticipate and get
around. And even if they don't get around at the first time, they'll get around at the second time.
I really think you should have been able to incapacitate the attacker as well.
And just like knock them off the train and the train moves on without them.
Right. Or the fort is like, you know,
you take enough damage and you're dead.
Uh, it should have been that in addition to the clock
because it, it, it makes it too easy.
I think that, I don't know that that kind of like will
just lead to turtling at that point.
Right. Like, sure.
Yeah. No, I mean, I'm not, I'm not saying
that the game is unbalanced.
So I feel like they, they had their reasons.
I just feel like the,
the, uh, the defender feels incredibly weak in both these scenarios.
Hmm. I guess I need to play
multiplayer. Well, I was able to successfully defend.
So it was Joe. Uh, but I do know that
like once I got better at attacking, Joe was no longer able to defend against me, or at least they
come, you know, in our game, come up with a strategy at enough time.
I'm sure he would have eventually
figured out a way to turn tides back, but it basically made it so that at one point I was losing
pretty badly. And then it just became a, well, now it's just, you know, a matter of how many times
can we do the train game before I take all your towns, all that to say the single soldier thing
also feels very strange because the whole thing is about this, you know, like your army, right.
And you're merging troops and how many cannons you have.
Cause remember, if you lose your,
if you win the fight, but still the opponent was able to take some of your cannons or cavalry or
infantry out that, that number sticks with you.
So that whole part is tracking.
But then at the end of the day, they just have like one lone guy go in to infiltrate this stuff.
It's like, not that you should have a cannon in this side scrolling thing.
That wouldn't make any sense
either, but the army count should matter for both sides too.
If you're defending, if nothing else,
then maybe like the amount of like, cause you have a, basically a lives pool as a defender
of how many guys you get to like interfere with the, the attacker.
And maybe it should also affect
how many knives you have.
I don't know, but I agree.
There should be something there.
Something to just, because this part really did feel like, and it's supposed to be right.
It is the, it is a skill check thing.
It is like a moment to shift tides without just being like, uh, I know
exactly how to, uh, take all your states, right?
It's like, no, you have to prove it in actual video
game gameplay.
Makes sense. It's the thing that separates it from the board game that Sean was
describing. I just am not completely sold on it.
The game originally came out on computers for, uh,
Amiga and Atari ST and a whole bunch of others.
DOS, uh, C64, ZX Spectrum, which I think they say
ZX Spectrum.
I like that. Should we be saying that going forward?
I call it the ZX Spectrum
because it's a European thing.
So, right.
And so it makes sense for this game to be a computer
thing. And it's kind of interesting that it came over to the NES, but sure, we'll take it.
What's more interesting is that after the release of this game and all of its, uh, ports to other
platforms, the, the license, right?
Of the blue coats kind of went silent and has like a very recent
explosion in the 20 in 2012 where two different games came out in 2012, uh, North and South,
the game. I don't know why they needed that.
The game part, like it, first off it was released on iOS.
So it's like, did they, were they worried about getting sued?
Yeah. It's this game remade.
Wow. Uh, so totally different graphics and everything, but like, yeah, it's this game, but also like,
were they worried about getting into, uh, like a lawsuit with a maps thing, like North and South,
like, uh, can't, you have to, you have to make sure it's identifiable the game.
And then there's also the blue coats North verse South, which makes, makes a lot more sense, right?
North verse South.
Is it also just this game?
It's a remake of this game came out in this, listen, that, that one,
the blue coats came out in June of 2012, North and South, the game came out in November of 2012.
Did, did like the copyright expire extra early?
I don't know, but if they're both remakes of the
exact same game made by two different companies, that's even more confusing to me.
Yes, they, they are.
Um, and what's even more confusing is, is that the, um, the first, the second one,
the blue coats North verse South, uh, the, the steam version and the console versions are all
delisted. So you can't even get them.
Darn. Yeah.
Then we went eight years without any North and
South games. And that was very sad, but thankfully, uh, on October 27th, 2020, the blue coats North and
South. It's like, how many variations of this title can you come up with?
It's not, it still feels
complicated to North and South.
It should be North versus South, right?
Or North South North North slash
South. Everybody's saying North and South, but nobody's saying South and North.
Well, there's a
reason for that. Okay, good.
Uh, anyway, that game in 2020 was released for Nintendo switch.
Uh, it's
by the same people who made, um, the blue coats North versus South and, um, uh, yeah, the one that
was delisted, but here's the kicker they added because now it's on switch.
They added an FPS, uh,
like battle.
No way. Yeah.
So there's still the, there's still the strategy stuff, but then when
you go into the battles, it's all, uh, FPS.
Like, is it a competent FPS or like, uh, from what I
watched it?
Yeah. It's probably just using the gun real engine.
Okay. Wasn't expecting that.
It's very strange. Yeah, I know.
I know. It's, it's $20 and it could be yours.
We'll see. Not delisted yet.
Uh, and here's the thing, uh, alternate history, civil war stuff, even if it's uncomfortable.
Um, it's a thing.
There's other media for it too.
Uh, notably Abraham Lincoln, vampire
hunter. I was thinking of the turtle.
Was that what you were expecting?
Yeah, no, no.
I'm thinking of, uh, that the one alt history author that people know about.
Is it the book, the guns
of the South? Yes.
Okay. Yeah. That's the time travelers arm the Confederacy with modern rifles
so that they can turn the tides of the civil war.
That is very much a turtle dove book.
Yes. Yeah.
Uh, so, you know, I, I like to think of Abraham Lincoln, vampire hunter because it did
take place during the civil war, right?
It has. I would imagine.
No, no, you know what I'm saying?
Like, it's like, it basically is like a redo of the war where now vampires are using the slaves as a
food source. Like that's kind of crazy.
Yeah. That's interesting.
I suppose. Not, not time travel
shenanigans to change the outcome of like, is anyone doing that for Germany?
Is anyone writing
books about time travelers assisting Hitler?
Isn't that like, isn't that man in the high
cat? No, that's not man.
Isn't that man in the high castle?
Yeah, that's actually true,
but that's alternate history, right?
Is this not alternate history?
No, no, no. That was a time
traveler thing. The guns of the South was like time travelers from the future got mad about the,
you know, they were like, Oh man, if only we could change that civil war.
So they go back in time.
I don't think, is that what happens in that Amazon series?
I mean, it was a Philip K.
Dick book. I know.
I know it was a book first.
Sure. But like, I'm just saying like, I didn't watch enough of it.
Is that, is it, is it revealed that they went, they traveled through time to do that shit?
I thought it was just like, Oh, I think it's, you know, again, this is this, maybe this is all just a spoiler
thing, but who gives a fuck about spoilers for, well, it's good that you give the warning though,
because I think I have not given the warning before, but I think it's more just like a weird
quantum time fluctuation, uh, because there is an awareness of a timeline in which the, the,
the allies won.
Got it. Is that the same thing then for all mankind?
Are you aware of that Apple
TV show? I'm aware of the Apple TV show, but I do not have Apple TV, so I'm not sure.
Uh, and then,
uh, the only other thing I had here was a video game, uh, called damn nation.
It's a steampunk
shooter released in 2009 for the PS three and three 60.
And it's a, uh, steampunk version
of the civil war.
Huh? Now that sounds interesting.
Uh, I guess, I, I, I, I guess, uh, I'm, I guess
I'm curious what you mean by that.
You're not, well, you're not picking, uh, you're not picking
sides there. You're not trying to rewrite history.
You're just doing it in, in steampunk form.
Now, if we're just sort of going off of vibes here, um, a game that I kind of want to try
was like, like a seventh generation FPS called, uh, I think it was darkest of days where you play as a,
um, you, you play as a, somebody that was supposed to die in the American civil war, but in the final
moments, some like inter time corporation comes in and like kidnaps you.
And it was like, uh, we're,
we're, we're basically like the, in that Loki show, like the authority to make sure the timeline
stay correct. And we need, we need great soldiers.
So we're, we're recruiting you to go into different
time periods and make sure that with our fancy technology that things go correctly.
Um, and just
a cool concept.
And no one's doing, uh, like time travel where they take the fire away from man,
you know, like we're, we're, people aren't going back far enough.
Right. I would do that.
Yeah. Yeah.
Just like stop the fire.
Like you don't know, you don't get that actually.
And they give it to lizards instead and lizards are like, Holy shit.
I would give it to lizards.
I think that like lizard people, whether they exist today or not, we need more of them.
What do you mean? Weather
lizard people might not exist, but you know, it does exist, Sean.
The essential games list.
That's right. And here's my vote for North and South.
Uh, first off, if we're doing essential
titles list, it's just not it North and South.
I'm just not a fan of it. I'd let it be known.
I don't hate it, but it just feels incorrect.
Uh, the actual game, very approachable.
You'll notice that in this game, you don't have to, um, like, uh, divvy out or ration out your rice for the winter.
You don't have to, um, you know, uh, swoon over, uh, another person's, uh, another captain's like
princess and, and marry families to create new dynasties.
There's a certain level of strategy
here and it's like just enough for anyone.
Uh, it's very accessible.
This game. Is it actually
fun though? Uh, I had a lot of fun playing it with Joe, like, as we were figuring it out,
but I think it was because like, it was as we were figuring it out.
I think once we figured it
out, we didn't like feel an urge to be like, Oh, and let's do, let's jump into another game.
Uh, it was kind of like, all right, that was North and South and we moved on.
So for that reason,
I'm going to leave it off the list, but I would also say that I think that the, uh, I was calling
them party games.
They're actually barely even mini games.
They're just kind of like action side
scrolling parts of this game.
Uh, those are, those could be a lot better than what they are.
They are, if anything, just little, uh, little breaks between the, uh, board game component of this,
which feels like the, uh, the largest and most important part of the game.
So it's a little too,
um, divided for me to put it on the essential games list, but I also don't think I'll be coming
back to this one.
Sean. Um, yeah, I, I think one of the things that really succinctly illustrates
how I feel about strategy games on the NES, um, was your comment about the rice.
Um, I, I really,
the amount of minutiae that these games have gotten into in the past, uh, for what it can actually
simulate and show you in a more, uh, a more visual and like gameplay wise, uh, has made me kind of
like, Oh, I kind of hate strategy on the NES.
And I guess this isn't really strategy or this is baby
strategy or strategy light.
But like I said, at the top of this episode, like this is the kind of,
this is the kind of strategy that I like.
Um, now to counter another thing that you said though,
like I do kind of like the whole, uh, gotta marry the princess.
If there was a way to make sure that
like, um, Robert E Lee or Stonewall Jackson had to get into like a diplomatic marriage with
Sherman or something like that.
Uh, that would be pretty interesting to me.
Um, I know that would,
that would be some pretty hardcore, uh, alternate history, but what else is there, uh, when you're
getting into these kinds of games?
Uh, that said, um, I don't know if this is like essential kind of
stuff. I, I would definitely say if you thought yourself a strategy game enjoyer before all the
games that we've played, but we're starting to second guess yourself, try this game out.
Uh, uh, it's goofy.
It's, uh, it's weird, but I think it scratches an itch that the Nobunaga likes have
not. Um, and it's definitely, it sounds like at least a cool multiplayer game, uh, judging by the
fun that, uh, Mike and Joe had without me.
So, uh, not essential, but I recommend it.
I will play every, uh, 1991 multiplayer game with you tomorrow.
Okay. Yeah, we'll do it.
We'll get them all tomorrow. That's how we do the show.
By the way, guys, we play every game for the year,
uh, in one day and then we just wait a week after week to review them.
So Joe and I played
North and South.
That was 2019, right?
Yeah. Back in 2019.
Uh, can't wait to get to Wario Woods,
which we played in 2020 during COVID.
No, this is all a joke.
Uh, the real story is that up next,
uh, is East and West.
Uh, we're going to take care of the other, uh, two things on the compass
because nobody ever made those games.
Is that like a Tupac versus Biggie sort of thing?
That's exactly what happened.
Yeah. It's kind of crazy, but you do, uh, you do, and it's not like
GTA or anything.
It's literally just this, but, uh, one script and all that stuff.
That's ok. That's ok.
That's ok.